[Music]
hey who's the current vice president
Camala Harris I love her why because
she's
black
sometimes our cold opens get right to
the heart of what we're doing on this
program and today is one of those days
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Rubin report
it's December 18th 2023 the year is
almost over but we've got a couple more
shows for you before we shut it down we
are live streaming on the rumble on the
YouTube and on the locals if you want to
join us for the postgame show it's Ruben
report. locals.com I just realized does
my voice sound a little horse today I
was at Josh Hammer former Ruben report
guest got married last night I was at
his wedding and uh it was it was a barn
burner with a lot of shots and a lot of
screaming and uh Dave ruin busted out
the dance moves it only happens once a
year I bust out all my Cosby moves which
uh well I guess not all my Cosby moves
but uh I do what I can out there anyway
I'm doing okay it's good to be with you
and yes that cold open uh of how people
can actually think that they like people
just because of their skin color that is
the theme today Elon Musk over the
weekend he was in Italy and he went on a
fiery tiate against the woke mind virus
and Dei which of course really should be
diie as he has pointed out many times uh
and we're going to see how this woke
mind virus this Progressive lunacy all
of this stuff that we're always talking
about how it it has leaked into
everything we got some clips from the
Boston who was a full-on racist it
leaked into the Smithsonian oh and a
senate staffer got banged in Amy clar's
chair in the Senate
chamber I guess we know why they call it
the chamber so uh anyway we're going to
talk about the immorality of Dei and uh
the collapse of our institutions and all
of that stuff let's dive right into it I
so basically we're showing you porn at
the end of the show I mean that's like I
was not my intention and you know I
guess we're not getting Iz but what can
you do anyway uh let's start with Elon
Musk he was in Italy and he had just you
know he has this really incredible way
of just I think very cleanly and calmly
explaining what the issues of the day
are uh here he is talking about the
dangers of the woke mind virus yeah
WM illness what's that virus yeah so so
he cominging to Europe I have to advise
you H yes well this is not something you
should import from America please don't
import the work mind virus is
bad um so the the I mean essentially
that to summarize maybe the work mind
virus it consists of creating very very
divisive um identity politics so it
actually amplifies W virus mind virus in
my view amplifies racism amplifies uh
frankly sexism and all the isms and
while claiming to do the opposite it it
actually divides people and makes them
uh sort of hate each other and it makes
people hate themselves yeah it makes
people hate themselves I think that has
become fairly obvious when you see the
purple haired out of shape screaming
people who are confused about what
gender they have and all that you know
uh as I always say it's like there were
all of these people all of these people
when say five or six years ago when a
bunch of us were talking about identity
politics and why it was dangerous and a
whole whole bunch of people kept saying
ah it's just it's never going to leave
college campuses when these kids get out
into the real world the real world will
show them what's up but we now know that
the real world basically folded like a
wet paper bag like it it has infected
everything and now you have the world's
richest man the renaissance man of our
day going to other countries warning oh
don't import that stuff from the United
States don't import these bad ideas
because they are taking down our country
and they are doing that
quite effectively uh he goes a bit
further talking about what they've done
what the woke mind virus has done to
Disney if we going to fight the work
mind virus then the work mind virus will
fight back and unfortunately Disney is
deeply infected with the work mind virus
in fact if you ask an AI what is the
most work company on Earth it's Disney
really you
know but and and you have to say what
what would I mean I think they should be
asking themselves what would Walt Disney
think of Disney today I think he's
turning in his
grave I think he's not happy sure sure
you know if if the namesake of the
company is not happy that's probably a
bad sign you know cuz wal Disney what
did he care about he cared about
bringing joy to people's lives he P you
know um M making wonderful things that
children and families could enjoy um and
uh you know it was it created some of
the the coolest um uh you know art in
the world and stuff that even 100 years
after it's created we still remember it
and it's still it's still a major thing
you have to say how great was Walt
Disney it was amazing um but now Disney
at least point now is deeply infected
with the workm virus I think that will
you know that will change over yeah oh I
hope so so the reason I wanted to show
you that clip is that when in the first
clip when he's talking about how you
should not import this stuff right what
he's saying is America is struggling
right now and of course it's not just
political side of things that we're
struggling with what we're struggling
with is that our cultural institutions
Disney which was just supposed to make
great things fun things capture the
imagination have kids looking at that
star in the distance going I could do
that that's the beauty of stories right
it has collapsed and that is a problem
because if we don't have anything that
will capture our imagination to give us
the good stories of humanity uh then we
don't have much of a future that's kind
of where we're at in the United States
right now uh he goes much further he was
not happy with Dei we're going to get to
that in just a second let me talk to you
guys about enviral cleanse real quick
you know if all home air purifiers are
the same then why did the US Department
of Defense select enviral cleanse to
protect and purify the air on board our
Navy ships why is it used in thousands
of classrooms across the country well
here's a couple reasons enviral cleanses
air purifiers have patented Earth
mineral technology and a hospital grade
HEPA filter they also destroy cold and
flu viruses covid allergy inflaming
toxins mold and even more so here's
enviral cleanses promise to you they
guarantee you'll experience far fewer
colds and allergies coupled with a
better ni sleep don't believe them well
they'll send you a free air quality
monitor to test the difference in your
home visit EK pure.com and use code Dave
for 10% off your enviral cleanse home
air purification unit and a free air
quality monitor plus fast free shipping
that's $150 in savings that's EK
pure.com promo code Dave EK pure.com Cod
Dave and now back to me let's throw to a
tweet because Elon was just on it over
the weekend about Dei yeah how about
this Dei must diie the point was to end
discrimination not to replace it with
different discrimination you know it's
interesting I think you could Whittle
that in a slightly different way I kind
of think the point of Dei was actually
to put discrimination into everything
he's he's given them he's like kind of
given them the best sort of outcome of
these ideas that what they these people
you know the road to hell is paid with
good intentions these were good people
at these places and these people wanted
equity and blah blah blah I actually
don't think so I really don't think so I
think the people that push the people
that put diversity equity and inclusion
departments in our corporations in our
government in all of these places I
actually think most of them actually
knew exactly what they were doing they
were instilling racism they were
unearthing old things that we had put to
bed but that's a we're we're just kind
of splitting the difference on
intentions right there let me show you
another tweet from Elon diversity equity
and inclusion are propaganda words for
racism sexism and other isms this is
just as morally wrong as other racism
and sexism Chang ing the target class
doesn't make it right quite correct
right if you just say we will not hire
white people because of equity or we're
going to make sure we don't have that
many Jews around cuz they got it too
good or something like that it's not
Reverse Racism it's good old-fashioned
racism now you're going to love this so
he puts out these tweets and this really
gets us to the heart of what today's
show is all about the director general
of the world health or organization the
wh his name is Tedros adnam Gabus I
think I pronounced that correctly uh he
saw elon's tweet and he retweeted it and
wrote this and listen this this is the
head of the who do you think this
organization has had a little too much
uh control over our lives after the the
three years of Co check this out Dear
Elon Musk I understand your perspective
but I respectfully disagree I can give
you many examples from my own experience
and from others diversity equity and
inclusion are essential principles that
aim to promote fairness equal
opportunities and respect for all
individuals regardless of their
background or identity perspectives and
experiences these principles are about
creating a more just and inclusive
Society let's work together to make sure
everyone is treated with equality and
dignity Connor leave that up for just a
second because the duplicitous double
language that they're using here so on
one hand he's saying okay diversity
Equity inclusion which we know is based
on judging people by race right like no
one's no one's debating that so he's
saying diversity equ inclusion are
important and then he's saying respect
for all individuals regardless of their
background or identity except the whole
thing is based on judging people by
their background and identity so what
happens when you put these really
ridiculous backwards racist ideas into
play what does that woke world will look
like well let's go to Boston we don't
talk about Boston too often on this show
I don't know what's going on in Boston I
you know I like uh the 80s Celtics great
team great team but we're going to take
you to Boston in one second let me talk
to you about boink box real quick uh 60%
you guys know this 60% of us pork
production comes from one company owned
by the Chinese and their Hogs are given
something called rack to pamine which is
banned in 160 countries including China
yet you find it in your grocery aisle
every day well guys there's a better way
I want to tell you about moink that's
moo oink moink delivers grass-fed and
grass finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door moink Farmers Farm like our
grandparents did and as a result moink
meat tastes like it should because
family farming Does It Better the moink
difference is a difference you can taste
and you can feel good knowing you're
helping Family Farms stay financially
independent as well you choose the meat
delivered in every box like rib eyes to
chicken breast to pork chops to salmon
fls and much more plus you can cancel
anytime Shark Tank host Kevin o called
moinks bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted and they guarantee you'll say
oink oink I'm just so happy I got moed
which is exactly what happened to the
Senate staffer we'll get to that in a
little bit keep American farming going
by signing up at Mbox docomo right now
and listeners of this show get free
ground beef for a year that's one of the
best ground beef you'll ever taste but
for a limited time inkbox.com Ruben Mbox
dcom rubben and now back to me okay so
if you want to see the idiocy the idiocy
and racism of wokeness and why Elon Musk
is going to Italy to tell them stay away
from these bad ideas Italians stick with
keeping Italy for the Italians and don't
infect your whole country with this evil
we've got a tweet here from the New York
Post we're going to Boston Boston mayor
Michelle woo shows off photo from
electeds of color holiday party after
defending Gathering a special moment so
look at that table the mayor of Boston
that woman right there Michelle woo who
appears to be Asian and generally
speaking uh the woke mind virus is not
too friendly to Asian people uh there
she is having a special Gathering of
people of color it's if if I said
there's a whole table full of colored
people there people would say that
that's racist but they call they had a
dinner and they said it's the electeds
of color anyway she has had a long
history of doing this kind of nonsense
it's actually crazy that we haven't done
more videos uh about this woman but here
she is defending her her holiday party
without white people given some of the
Strife that exists though in this
Council you concern this lens itself at
all to further
divisiveness no I mean um again this is
a a a group that has been in place for
many many years we want to be a city
where everyone's identity is embraced
and that there are spaces and
communities that we can help support oh
there are spaces and communities that we
can help support so we can look at a
bunch of people by their skin color and
say Don't eat with us don't come to this
dinner party that's what we used to call
racism you might know that back in the
day when we were having the Civil Rights
Movement black people wanted to get into
say white country clubs and there was a
bunch of white people that said we want
to have our own white spaces and they
were known as the racists back in the
day that's what you people would call
the white supremacists of our day if a
bunch of white people wanted to have
dinner with no colored people as you
call them you'd call them racist so it's
racist whichever way it goes but she
continued I think we've we've had
individual conversations with everyone
so people understand that it was truly
just a an honest mistake that went out
in in typing the email field and um I
look forward to celebrating with
everyone at the holiday parties that we
will have besides this one as well so um
it is my intention that we can again um
be a city that lives our values and
create space for all kinds of
communities to come together she's
saying everything at and nothing at once
right we should have parties for
everybody we had this party for the
colard we'll have some other parties for
some other people it was a typo like
these people are just absolutely
worthless and we have put them into the
system they're not worthless they are
useful idiots she strikes me as a useful
idiot I don't know who is pulling the
strings behind her she doesn't seem
particularly bright and it's like lady
you're racist now you if you imagine if
you're just a white guy in Boston you're
Larry Bird you're wandering why wouldn't
you Larry Bird why wouldn't you invite
Larry Bird to your Boston dinner party
that's everybody's dream to have in
Boston to have dinner with Larry Bird
give me another give me a hockey player
up in Boston who Tom Tom Brady Tom Brady
Tom Brady give me a couple more Boston
White people we got Larry Bird Tom Brady
Bill bich Bill bellich do we have anyone
not involved in sports in Boston oh what
about Ted Danson from cheers that was in
Boston Conor give me something here I
always turn to you for white references
give me one more one more a hockey
player from Boston uh I don't watch
hockey Bill bur Bill Burr is he from
Boston he's a comedian we're told he's
from Boston okay anyway that would be a
great white dinner I would enjoy that
dinner anyway um Michelle woo I want to
throw back to something during Co so you
remember our summer of love when black
lives matter was rampaging through
everything antifa and in the name of
Tolerance and diversity that were
burning down stores and beating people
and all that uh here she is during those
riots warning people about white
supremacy across the Boston Police
Department the uh Transit Police the
state police the FBI and all of our
partners in law enforcement and Public
Safety there's constant communication
about the impending um actions of any
known groups we continue to monitor the
situation and to work closely with
community members most of all we want to
ensure that community members are
empowered in uh communicating anything
that you may see or hear or um read
about on social media to to please air
on the side of reaching out to local
public safety officials so that we can
have the most information at hand and we
will continue to work in partnership
with community members as we strategize
and plan and coordinate um to respond to
not oneof incidence but this growing
rise and Trend in white supremacy yes
because you do remember all of the white
people in the name of reigning Supreme
who were burning down all of the
buildings it's all nonsense you I know
you guys get it I know you get it more
importantly than anything she said right
there I got a list of a couple other
great white people from Boston you got
your Ben Affleck you got Mark Wahlberg
you got Matt Damon Barbara Walters Steve
Carell John F
Kennedy white people is there anything
better anyway uh let's jump over to uh
what's going on in Congress we're not up
to the butt sex thing yet we'll get to
that in a second but something else did
happen uh Congress you know they have
these hearings and mostly in these
hearings it's people being exposed to be
complete idiots and nothing really
happens afterwards uh but here is a
really interesting video this is
Congressman Greg Murray uh talking to
the Secretary of the Smithsonian Lonnie
G Bunch
III and you will see how anti-white woke
propaganda has even leaked into the
Smithsonian enjoy this is in the
Smithsonian assumptions about white
culture and it says rugged individualism
family structure emphasis on scientific
method history Protestant work ethic
relig religion no tolerance from
deviation from a single God concept this
is
absolute anti-racial
propaganda why would anything like this
be in the Smithsonian Institute now it's
my understanding what I think you're
seeing I can't really see it is you
should be very well versed in this you
were the head of the Smithsonian at the
time let me explain what it is is there
was a document that is the whiteness
document that was put up online that I
took down immediately because I think
that the document itself was wrong and
flawed I do think however it's important
for the Smithsonian to help the country
grapple with questions of race so I'm
not going to run away from that but I
agree with you very much that that
document is not the kind of document
that should be at the Smithsonian and if
it's what I think it is I pulled that
down how does this help us with
race do is divide us this is divisive
language saying that white people any we
don't tolerate any deviation except a
single God
concept how is that helpful I don't
understand that I I I wish somebody
could explain that to me I want to give
the the head of the Smithsonian credit
for just a moment which is that they did
actually take that document down and and
what he said related to the Smithsonian
and and any Museum that it's relevant
dealing with the issues of race in an
honest way would be just fine right like
that's like a kid in a public school
learning about race learning about an
honest assessment of History nobody's
debating that the reason I'm showing you
that is the fact that that document was
part of a Smithsonian exhibition that it
was on their website that it got in
there in the first place tells you all
you need to know about the people that
are are running the Smithsonian it tells
you all you need to know about again how
this thing has infected all of our
institutions so yes it is just fine that
you took it down that you did the right
thing when you were exposed right but
the fact that that got there that kids
learned from that imagine you're a white
kid at the Smithsonian with your class
and you walk into the Smithsonian you
walk into any Museum where they're where
they're teaching any of this nonsense
and You by the nature of your skin color
are the guilty one and then let's Flash
Forward a little bit so now you're
taught that you're in you're sixth
seventh grade you go to the Smithsonian
you read about how basically you're a
white supremacist and your ancestors
were all evil and everything else now
you're in high school and you're
applying for colleges and sudden you
realize that it's going to be much
harder for you to get into a college
because you're white and because Equity
has now been pushed into all of these
colleges uh they're going to take the
black kid instead of you but you make it
into some school not a school that you
should have got into you make it into
some other school because they're
discriminating against you as a white
person or a Jewish person or they're by
the way they're doing it to Asians too I
don't think woo realizes that in Boston
but now it's a little also harder to get
into grad school or it's a little harder
to get that job at that company because
they have a DE I uh program in their in
their system as well do you see how this
could lead to an actual collapse of the
entire American system when you take out
meritocracy when you take out believing
that the individual is the most
important thing and you unearth all of
the old racism you just repackage the
racism that we all got rid of but where
does this all stem from it stems now or
how has it burst forth It's from raising
an entire generation if not two
generations in America into thinking
that they are either the oppressors or
the oppressed I want to show you
something from Chris rupo over at the
Manhattan Institute who's been on the
show a bunch of times he tweeted this
out this is wild
shock
79% of Americans between 18 and 24
believe that white people are oppressors
and that this ideology should be favored
today at universities and for employment
the racial retrograde has begun and he
shows a couple charts there laying that
out do you realize how absolutely
dangerous this is guys America the idea
of America you're tired and you're poor
and you're huddled masses and as I
always say guys every single person
watching this whether you're first
generation second generation third
generation or your parents came your
ancestors came on the Mayflower just
think of every every I just know this
every single one of you watching this
with almost no exception you have it so
much better than your ancestors did I
damn well know I did right my
grandfather growing up in a room with
his father passed away when he was 2
years old and he grew up in a
one-bedroom tenement in the Lower East
Side with six brothers and sisters like
and everyone has stories like that but
why did their ancestors come here it was
because there was the promise of this
place known as the United States of
America where it didn't matter what
color you were or what religion you were
or any of those other things and now
they've dumped sexuality into it and
gender and everything else but we have
we have we had the dream and the
question is do we have it anymore are we
actually getting to the point where
we've sort of crossed the uncanny valley
and we will not have this anymore like
maybe we are kind of there but we better
damn well fight because if we're not
there we still have a chance but if you
want to see how this infects absolutely
everything check out this tweet from NBC
News it just infects everything NB NBC
News this is the news organization of
NBC when you buy Santa pajamas for your
kids do you pause to examine the color
of Santa's skin when you have black
children one parent says it's important
to know they it's important they know
someone is magical and a and a it's so
stupid I can't even read it when you
have black children one parent says it's
important they know someone as magical
and as amazing as Santa can be black
like them too now first off look they
they capitalize black black should not
be capitalized black is a color it's a
big Zippity Dippity it shouldn't be
capitalized but also when you have black
children one parent says guys NBC News
went to one parent and one parent felt
that and then they tweet that out and
millions of people see it by the way NBC
news they have an entire section on
their website dedicated to black people
check this out NBC BK stories issues and
opinions for the African-American
perspective uh Connor uh could you go
over to NBC news right now and and do
they have a white section is there NBC
Wht do they have the white section over
at they no it's not Pages Pages
down error
303 anyway you guys get it look on the
racial front this is what they've done
with this oppressed oppressor thing
right so black people are oppressed and
whites are the oppressor but what about
the gender front right it's that men are
the oppressors and women are the
oppressed so here is Will Ferell
Hollywood actor Will Ferell who is
Ferell Ferell will Ferell yes that
sounds weird to me is Hollywood actor
Will Ferell he is at the women in
entertainment Gala held at the Beverly
Hills Hotel and here he is explaining
that the day of the man is coming to a
close forget about the entertainment
world isn't it isn't it just time
isn't it just time for women to run the
planet I I
mean I'm I'm s I'm not just trying to
Plate you I
swear but I don't know what else to do
because
we men uh we've been running the show
since what 10,000 BC something like that
and we're not doing so good
so please can you guys just take take
over I'm not trying to play Kate you
here's the most pandering dous nonsense
I could possibly say yes okay women just
run the world men retire men stop
working underground you know in septic
tanks and buildings and climbing High to
do all these crazy things and getting
out there and doing engineering and
fixing things stop doing women will just
take over women will they want like some
sort of like Bizarro woke Planet of the
Apes situation that really is what these
people want men will live in cages and
women will run rampant and lesbians will
take over and it's just like that really
is my Theory and action right
there like will I have just no doubt
that Will Ferrell's wife is a feminist
right and this guy and he also works in
Hollywood so he wants to stay in good
with the wokes but at the end of the day
does he really think women should rule
it's just nonsense saying women should
rule the world is as nonsensical as
saying just men should rule the world
right like you should judge people
individually some women are great
authors some men are great authors but
not every woman like you get it you get
it anyway the guy just wants a blow job
he just wants a blow job but but who
doesn't at the end of the day uh but
guys this is exactly this thing is
exactly why woke is is wrong it's
immoral and it's evil because it's it
eliminates Equal justice under the law
and due process right instead of being
judged on your actions you are judged on
your immutable characters characters
there was a
guy MLK you may have heard of him he
wanted his children and his
grandchildren to not be judged by the
color of their skin but by the content
of their character but they've done this
of course with race and they have done
this with gender and now they are doing
it with sexuality and uh I just have to
warn you before we do this segment I
don't know what's going to come out of
my mouth we're going to show you some
strange pictures and uh a guy
got uh well how are we going to say this
how are we going to say this well here
let's just show you a tweet we'll show
you a tweet I think we're blurring
something out uh exclusive Senate
staffer caught filming gay sex tape in
Senate hearing
room and uh yes uh it's true uh Greg
price who's an actual journalist he
tweeted this out can confirm that the
senator Carden staffer who filmed
himself having sex in a senate hearing
room is this guy Aiden ma seori he's
also the same guy who yelled free
Palestine at Jewish representative Max
Miller on Wednesday uh here's an image
of Aiden with the president of the
United States yeah so there and then
well beneath it is him doing his thing
um I'd rather not have a referendum on
uh gay sex or sex in general or whatever
people have sex in all sorts of weird
places like I don't know how this kid
did not think this was going for Not
only was the guy banging him filming it
that's one thing but like they have
cameras in these places there are
cameras basically everywhere did he not
realize or did he want to get caught or
anything else uh anyway uh he got uh he
got banged and then he got fired uh here
we go from NBC news they finally look at
this NBC is on a tear look at this
headline so Ben carden's office
has parted ways with a staffer who
conservative news outlets alleged was
shown in a leaked video having sex in
the Senate hearing room what do you mean
conservative news outlets alleged it
here's the picture
is conservative this guy I mean he's
he's on a Ledge I don't know if that has
anything to do with a ledge oh and by
the way if even funnier part of this
thing it turns out that it was Amy
clar's chair there's Amy kachar let's go
back to the picture of the guy he's on
Amy kobar's chair one more time to Amy
kachar and and it's alleged it's alleged
NB everyone at NBC should be fired like
that place should go under today it
didn't the conservative news outlets are
pouncing because some guy got pounded
and
we but now I want to show you something
that is the entire thesis of today's
show because if you view the world in
the oppressed oppressor narrative then
even if you are getting ass blasted on
the senate floor you will figure out a
way to consider yourself the victim so
here is now the statement from Aiden
Mass SAS the guy who this did this thing
uh here's his response this has been a
difficult wait I'll try to do this in a
gay voice this has been a difficult time
for me as I've been attacked for who I
love to pursue a political agenda while
some of my actions in the past have
shown poor judgment I love my job and I
would never disrespect my workplace any
attempts to characterize my actions
otherwise are fabricated and I will be
exploring all the legal options that are
available to to be in these matters as
for accusations regarding Max Miller I
have never seen the congressman and I
have no opportunity or cause to yell or
confront him yay um I'm sorry put the
statement up one more time because the
the I just there's one part of this that
is just mind-blowing to me first off
well no there's a couple things so it's
not no one's attacking him for who he is
he probably got the job in part because
he's gay in the first place but they're
saying as I have been attacked for who I
love it's not who you
love should I draw it I don't even know
what I can do at this point like you
can't do that in the
Senate the Senators are usually screwing
us the American people but that's a
metaphor you can't actually do it with
these people but put the thing up again
put it up again uh and then I love I
love my job and I would never disrespect
my workplace I'm just telling both of
you right now if either of you ever on
that desk right there Phoenix is like
that's it I'm out of here he just
retired right now it's insane uh anyway
it's important that in government
and in the society that we live in that
we have respectful people in the
government right we have to have a
certain degree of decency of decorum etc
etc and we found this new Joe Biden uh
campaign video that I thought maybe
would help clean things
up character is on the ballot compassion
is on the ballot decency science
democracy they're all on the
ballot who we are as a nation what we
stand for and most importantly who we
want to be that's all on the ballot how
old are you 17 the choice could not be
more
clear God bless the internet uh by the
way I just got a text that apparently uh
he's Aiden has issued another statement
and he's saying that uh the only reason
he did that was because uh he respects
the senator so much that he just thought
he would bend over backwards for
him that's a old joke from The Golden
Girls uh anyway uh what is the end
result of all of this well I think the
end oh God be a miracle it will be a
miracle if this show is put out there um
let's go to a clip that we showed you
last week because think this actually
guides this thing quite well uh this is
Jordan Peterson explaining to Kathy n uh
sorry this is Jordan Peterson explaining
to Kathy Newman not Nome that the
philosophy behind the social justice
Warriors this thing of putting us all
into these boxes and and just unearthing
all of the evil and repackaging it and
everything else that it's the same exact
ideology that was ushered in by some of
the worst people of all time in this
case he's talking about China's ma dong
take a look comparing them with you know
German Mau who saw the deaths of
millions of people well even if the
activists you know they're trans people
too they have a right to say these
things yeah but they don't have their
compare them to Chairman Mau or you know
I could pinache orust pinache I mean you
know this is grossly insensitive I
didn't compare them to pinic I did
compare them he was an authoritarian
he's a right winger though I was
comparing them to the left-wing
totalitarians and I do believe they are
leftwing totalitarians under ma millions
of people died I mean there's no
comparison between Ma and a trans
activist is there why not because trans
activists aren't killing millions of
people the philosophy that's guiding
their utterances is the same philosophy
you're saying that trans activists could
lead to the deaths of millions of people
what no I'm saying that the philosophy
that drives their utterances is the same
philosophy that already has driven us to
the deaths of millions of people okay
tell us how that philosophy is in any
way comparable sure that's no problem
the first thing is is that the
philosophy presumes that group identity
is
Paramount that's the fundamental
philosophy that drove the Soviet Union
and Ma China and it's the fundamental
philosophy of the left-wing activists
its identity politics doesn't matter who
you are as an individual it matters who
you are in terms of your group identity
do you guys realize that the transition
we went from the guy doing butt stuff
and then we showed you a video where
they're talking about ma
dong do we have a laugh track we don't
have the laugh track here somewhere or
mous
dong anyway the point of what Jordan is
laying out there is that this movement
which Elon Musk is saying must die right
Dei must die what Jordan is now saying
is that it is the same it is the same
notion that people get in their brains
that we should judge Everybody by these
ridiculous things and then you end up
killing an awful lot of people because
it's deeply
antihuman now I want to connect this to
something else this is this is really
wild because you can combine you can
connect this to the depopulation
movement so this is Bill Gates speaking
at the world economic Forum in 2008
talking to K CLA Schwab uh and he's
explaining uh his mission to depopulate
the third world depopulate less people
there now that's kind of sounds
anti-human and he's saying it to be
positive listen to The Backwards
rationality here what would you like to
see as your leg Legacy in 10 15
years uh of the new work of the new work
yeah if you're new function well I I set
very ambitious goals because I'm quite
optimistic if you look at say the the 20
diseases uh that our Global health
program goes after I'd hope that within
15 years over half of those we could
have had a very dramatic impact you know
huge change in the uh mortality rates in
developing countries which then has this
effect of reducing population growth
that's the this big benefit that then
makes everything like education and
nutrition a lot easier so I I have very
high expectation you get the circular
thing he's doing there so on one hand it
sounds like he's doing something good
right I want to eliminate these diseases
that kind of sounds good even though for
some reason it seems like he had
something to do with Co and he's now
become the largest Farmland owner in the
United States and there's a whole bunch
there but he's saying okay we want to
eliminate these diseases that sounds
good but why does he want to eliminate
these diseases because he knows that
when you eliminate these diseases and
then societies get a little healthier
people have less children so then he's
he's pushing
depopulation as a good thing these
people are deeply deeply anti-human so
what can you do about them what can you
do well you can laugh at them you can
can make fun of them Elon Musk not a fan
of Bill Gates he put this one up in case
you need to lose a boner fast this has
really been a theme of a show look at
that Elon Musk looking like the pregnant
man emoji and yes that is an actual
emoji on your iPhone they have a
pregnant man emoji uh the other thing of
course that you can do to these people
is not just make fun of them but you can
basically tell them to go f themselves
you might remember this clip of Elon
about two weeks ago the approach to um
some of the stuff you're doing with with
AI has been very specific right there's
not a let let the chips fall where they
may approach to those businesses I don't
think no we focus on making the best
products and and and Tesla is gotten to
where it's gotten with no advertising at
all I understand that Tesla currently
sells two twice as much uh in terms of
electric vehicles as the rest of
electric car makers in United States
combined Tesla has done more to help the
environment
than uh all other companies
combined would be fair to say that
therefore as a leader of the company
I've done more for the environment than
everyone any single human on earth how
do you feel about
that how feel about that yeah no I'm I'm
asking you personally how you feel about
that because this goes we're talking
about power and influence and I'm saying
I'm saying what what I care about is the
the reality of goodness not the
perception of it and what I see all over
the place is people who care about
looking good while doing
evil
them
okay okay so what can you do you can
make fun of them right so that's the
Bill Gates Emoji tweet right then you
can tell them to f off right that's good
too but what's really the thing you can
do it's actually the third thing and the
third thing is that you can promote
virtue by offering a more positive
vision for the world I I'm very I'm very
prum I'm very pro- civilization I I'm in
favor of uh Humanity um and and our
Collective Consciousness expanding um on
Earth and going beyond Earth um being a
multiplanetary civilization and being
out there among the stars and finding
out the nature of the universe like all
the things that you know it's that seems
like to me and you know exciting thing
something you can get really excited
about is is you can get excited like we
want to have ideas that make you look
forward to waking up in the morning look
forward to the day look forward to the
future and you know so you have to
say what what excites you about the
future what moves your heart about the
future what makes you say like yes I'm
glad about what will happen in the
future that's what we must you know
focus on and that's that's why we have
to have a new generation we've got to
build and we got to grow and and uh like
I said we understand this understand the
the the the nature of this beautiful
universe that we find ourselves in and
the meaning of life or even what
questions to ask about you know meaning
of life um let us explore this wondrous
creation and and have a good time doing
it
yeah that's my
philosophy go here humans go humans yes
team
Humanity right like that's it that's it
and we all know it it's not whittling us
down to our genitals and our skin color
and the rest of this nonsense like there
is an Incredible Universe to explore and
that guy is literally doing it with
rocket ships like it might be within our
lifetime it actually almost undoubtedly
will be in our lifetime unless they
totally sabotage him that we will get
some sort of colony on another planet
Mars or elsewhere that we will start
uncovering the great Mysteries of the
universe maybe we meet alien life forms
the the Litany of things that we can
think of and and things that we cannot
think of that are all like right there
they're right in front of us if we just
have that sense of adventure and we want
to and we want to do what humans have
always done which is climb the highest
mountain and then find another highest
mountain to go climb and they don't do
it going well how many black people and
how many lesbians are joining me on this
trip you find the best people to go do
those things and I guarantee you by the
way that's what Elon Musk is going to do
as he sends rocket ships into space and
as he builds electric cars and
everything else right so I'm not sitting
here worshiping the guy I'm just saying
here's a guy that's pretty popular that
has a lot of influence that's doing good
stuff and maybe we should all be a
little bit more like that and following
those dreams that that's what makes a
lot more sense and then and then
contrast that to a guy like Bill Gates
who's like I'll solve diseases so that
we have less people on Earth because I'm
the good guy like the human desire to
reproduce to explore like it is so
innate when I am playing with these kids
in the morning just like I was this
morning and they're climbing all over
the couch we don't have dining room
chairs anymore we had to move all of our
chairs out of the dining room because
they're climbing up chairs to get on the
table so they can get on the table so
they can climb on something else and
it's like we the because because it is
innate in humans to explore to climb to
dream all of those things so how about
do that instead of getting banged on the
senate floor I'm Dave Rubin we've got a
postgame show for you at Ruben report.
locals.com in just a second oh it's meme
Monday also here's my meme that I put up
at the at the locals Community this is
Jaylen I'm in a lot of trouble after
today thank God I'm I'm the owner and
operator of this production company
otherwise we could be in a lot of
trouble uh my full interview with Ted
Cruz is up uh all about it's actually
kind of about some of the things we we
discussed today uh as a reminder we have
a new Twitter account Ruben report show
if you want to catch clips from the show
uh we have a long cold close here for
you involving my friend Michael nolles
but I think you're going to enjoy it and
we'll see everybody at the postgame show
in just a moment come into this
conversation you know trying to hold
this moral superiority but then when I I
try to be moral when I can but I right
but when I use inclusive language which
it only takes a couple extra syllables
to use inclusive language and it seems
to include people who don't CL you know
ident identify as women but can become
pregnant
so like a person who's born a woman and
then identifies as a man and is pregnant
yeah so you're telling me that in order
to be a moral person I need to accept
the idea that a man someone who is born
a man and looks like a man can really
become a woman that's that's a a
prerequisite of my being a moral person
I mean yes to to me it is because if you
are trying to deny someone of their
identity and deny what they're life
experiences then that doesn't seem like
a moral stance to me I want to be
accepting and I want to respect people's
life experiences and respect the way
that they want to identify and respect
the way that they want to present
themselves to the world Bronte I would
like to identify I do identify actually
as the correct person on this issue of
abortion I identify as being correct and
more correct than you on this issue and
I would just ask that you accept and
confirm my uh
[Applause]
[Music]
identity